christophe prat secrétaire fédéral fo
cheminots monsieur pratte bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vient de le voir un
manifestation aujourd'hui à paris le
cortège va partir dans quelques minutes
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation
ben on attend bien sûr du monde déjà
dans la rue on attend prouver
une fois de plus au gouvernement que
nous sommes toujours mobilisés nous
sommes toujours farouchement opposé au
projet de réforme de retraite par points
est ce que vous pensez qu actuellement
la rue a toujours les moyens de faire
pression sur le gouvernement
l'art ou la wii la rue a toujours les
moyens de faire pression là la
difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
d'essayer de coordonner le tous ensemble
et on voit que depuis maintenant trois
mois
les grèves les manifestations on a
toujours su les organisées a appelé les
gens à se mobiliser maintenant ce qu'on
essaye de construire ccc une réellement
une action qui permettra de mettre tout
le monde en même temps dans la rue quand
vous dites tout le monde vous parlez du
secteur privé également parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec que non il ya
beaucoup majorité en tous cas des
personnes travaillant dans le secteur
public doit sur le secteur privé et le
secteur public de toute façon dès le
départ nous l'avions dit ce n'est pas
une réforme qui concerne uniquement un
secteur où une certaine catégorie de
personnel c'est une réforme qui concerne
l'ensemble des salariés et des futurs
pensionnés donc oui surtout je dirais
même les salariés du privé puisque
aujourd'hui représentent 97% des gens
concernés par la nouvelle réforme qui
veulent mettre en place
est ce qu'un nouveau blocage au sein de
la sncf de la ratp
est-ce que c'est envisageable c'est même
envisagé je dirais nous ne sommes pas du
tout au bout de la contestation ne
sommes pas du tout non plus au bout de
ce qu'on peut faire ou montrer nous
sommes dans une phase justement depuis
quelques quelques jours et quelques
semaines 2
dirt coordination un petit peu des
forces il ya des assemblées générales
déjà vous êtes dit qu'il y aurait encore
des grèves oui il ya encore des
assemblées générales il ya encore grève
dans ce pays est ce qu'on veut nous
faire croire c'est que la contestation
s'est eu finalement et c'est tout
l'inversé qui se fait aujourd'hui on
continue à informer les salariés dans
les entreprises par des assemblées
générales ont continué aussi informer
les citoyens dans leur plus grande
majorité par des tracts par des
informations tous les jours alors il
faut donc vous faites partie a quitté la
conférence de financement c'était hier
il me semble aujourd'hui c'est la cgt
qui claquent la porte à cette conférence
est ce que la politique de la chaise
vide vous semble-t-elle une bonne
politique adoptée aujourd'hui face au
gouvernement
alors c'est pas la politique de la
chaise vide puisque nous cette
conférence on l'a on n'avait pas demandé
on en n'était pas demandeur ça a été
cette conférence est d'abord l'échec de
la négociation
déjà la concertation pendant plus de
deux ans avec les organisations
syndicales qui aboutit à une très forte
contestation qui s'est mis en lumière
début décembre par la grève est donc
s'est déclenché cette conférence a été
un petit peu d'essayer déjà de contenir
la grève qui faisait rage au mois de
décembre mois de janvier on a décidé d'y
participer
et puis au bout de toutes façons de d'à
peine quelques réunions on se rend bien
compte que ça ne sert pas à grand chose
puisque les thèmes ont été ouverts avec
des interdits on n'avait pas le droit de
parler de la hausse des cotisations on
n'avait pas le droit de parler de
certains thèmes
ce qui fait que toute façon c'est un
échec dès le départ cette concertation
donc là bas les masques et puis il est
temps d'en sortir
alors vous disiez tout à l'heure que la
rue encore les moyens de faire pression
sur le gouvernement un gouvernement qui
pourtant utilisent aujourd'hui le 49-3
oui voilà c'est une provocation de plus
un mépris de plus par rapport à la
grogne qui fait rage depuis des mois je
le dis
non le 49-3 de toute façon on s'y
attendait quelque part ça a été préparée
depuis quelques jours on essayait de
préparer un petit peu l'opinion à ce
qu'il pouvait se passer mais 49 3 ou pas
nous on n'en veut pas de cette réforme
donc la matraque gouvernementales qu'ils
ont brandi de toute façon ça ne
ça ne pousse car encore une fois à
énerver les gens contre ces méthodes
comment vous envisager la suite eh bien
on envisage on envisage très
sérieusement on est on n'est pas abattu
on n'est pas je dirais résigné ce qu'il
faut aujourd'hui c'est continuer à notre
travail d'information comme je disais et
on appelle de toutes façons le plus
grand nombre des citoyens des salariés
en colère des mets prisé des gens qui
sont exclus et qui demain auront
peut-être une double ou triple peine en
ayant eu toute une vie de travail et ans
on leur garantit aucun avenir après le
travail et aujourd'hui c'est ça le fond
du sujet dont on voudrait parler
nous ce qu'on voudrait parler c'est d'un
projet alternatif qui permettent de
rassurer les gens qui permettent de les
encourager à rester dans l'emploi à
acquérir tout un stade
je dirais de droit tout au long de leur
carrière et de pouvoir en bénéficier un
jour christophe prat merci d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire fédéral fo cheminots merci
merci